welcome to the science Asylum I am Nick
lucid in my last video I tried to use
black holes to explain movie science and
I've gotten a lot of comments asking
about them too lucky for you dead stars
happen to be my specialty mmm maybe
we'll do a list I love lists let's ask a
bunch of questions and call it basic
facts about black holes facts what are
black holes whoa they're killers start
with a smaller question where do black
holes come from that's better when stars
completely run out of fuel they become a
stellar corpse in other words a dead
star you get a black hole when that star
is really big let's take a look at one
of those really big stars at the end of
its life you've got normal star stuff
happening in the outer layers like the
chromosphere giving the star its reddish
orange color and convection currents
carrying heat and light from the core to
its surface the core is what's going to
turn into the black hole so let's zoom
in a little it kind of looks like an
onion with all its fusion layers
hydrogen into helium helium into carbon
carbon into oxygen each step in work
creating bigger and bigger atomic nuclei
all releasing energy in the process
until we get to iron anyway the iron
nucleus has the highest binding energy
of all the elements so fusing it into
bigger stuff takes more energy than it
releases it's the end of the line once
the star starts making iron it has a
matter of days before it runs out of
fuel
yes in a lifetime of millions of years
the last stage takes days how massive
are they that's actually a tricky
question first we usually measure mass
in kilograms but if we did that for
stars we'd be talking in millions of
trillions of trillions which we know the
human brain can't possibly comprehend so
we use the Sun as a baseline to make the
numbers more manageable instead of
saying the Sun is two million trillion
trillion kilograms we say that it's one
solar mass so much better second not all
the mass of the star ends up in the
black hole let's take another look at
those layers in the final moments the
core is basically a big clump of iron
plasma since fusion of iron consumes
more energy than it releases there's no
more outward pressure to balance gravity
the core suddenly collapses under its
own weight and releases more energy than
the star has seen in its entire lifetime
this
release of energy blast most of the
outer layers away in a brilliant
explosion called a supernova only the
iron core is left to continue collapsing
into the black hole the smallest black
hole that can form this way is about
three solar masses but remember that's
just the core if the core is three solar
masses then the star it came from is
about 20 solar masses that's 20 times
the mass of the Sun how big are they in
size though that question can be a bit
misleading black holes are generally
pretty simple things the actual black
hole is a singularity all of the mass of
that stellar core compressed so much
under gravity that it's essentially just
a single point in space it doesn't have
size when physicists talk about the size
of a black hole they're actually talking
about the event horizon past that
boundary not even light can escape and
that's the universal speed limit so
nothing gets out light is what allows us
to see things if light can't escape then
we can't see anything
hence the name black hole how big that
event horizon is depends on how massive
the black hole is its size is given by
the Schwarzschild radius which looks
something like this
or more simply one point eight three
miles for solar mass for the three solar
mass black hole mentioned earlier that's
a little over five and a half miles or
11 miles across how big can they get
super big even though they don't start
very big they can gobble up more stuff
and get bigger over time there's a
supermassive one at the center of all
the big galaxies including the Milky Way
ours is about four million solar masses
which means it's about 17 times the size
of the Sun there's one in the galaxy NGC
1277 that's probably about five billion
solar masses although it's difficult to
get data about black holes because you
know they're black anyway back to the
original question what are black holes
they're massive black balls of death but
only if you get too close so what do you
think of black holes let us know in the
comments and until next time remember
it's okay to be a little crazy
Hey look what I made what are you doing
so idiot how are we gonna get out of
this mess you always figure out a way